what we're going to do in this video is
a deep dive into the difference between
demand and quantity demanded in
particular we're gonna focus on change
in demand versus change in quantity
demanded and so just as context I have
price versus quantity here for Brand X
of cars in a certain market and you see
the demand curve for Brand X of cars and
we see that it follows the classic law
of demand at a high price there is a low
quantity demanded and so this is already
trying to draw the distinction a
quantity demanded so I'll call this QD 1
is associated with a particular point on
the demand curve it's not the whole
curve itself when people talk about
demand they're talking about the whole
curve but just following on what I just
said following the law of demand at a
low price this is associated with if we
go to the demand curve a high quantity
demanded quantity demanded 2 and so to
be very particular about this quantity
demanded is associate with a particular
point on the demand curve while the
demand curve is a set of all of these
points that show how price and quantity
are associated so with that out of the
way to make things more tangible let's
go through a bunch of different
circumstances and think about whether
they would result in a change in demand
versus a change in quantity demanded so
in this first scenario we say car
dealerships slash prices by 10% would
that result in a change in demand which
would involve shifting our demand curve
or would it involve a shift along the
curve a change in quantity demanded
pause the video and try to figure it out
well there's a couple of ways to think
about it in order to shift the demand
curve itself the one way I think about
it is if you were to pick a given price
if you were to pick a given price it
does what's described here in any way
shift the quantity that would be
demanded at that price well no this is
not shifting how much consumers would
want to buy
at that price this is just this is
shifting the price itself so this is
going to be a shift along the demand
curve so this would be a scenario where
maybe the equilibrium price and we'll
talk more about that in future videos
maybe the equivalent the equilibrium
price and quantity demanded are
associated with that point right over
here before car dealers slash their
prices so let's take all this quantity
demanded let's call that quantity
demanded three but then when they
slashed their prices the prices go down
and so we end up with this point on our
demand curve and so this would be
quantity demanded quantity demanded four
so this would be a change in quantity
demanded right over here so change I'll
do Delta for a change in change in
quantity demanded and in this case the
quantity demanded would go up what about
the price of gasoline increases pause
this video think about what would happen
would that change the quantity demanded
for the cars or it shift the entire
demand curve well I'll do the same
exercise pick a given price let's say
we're at this price right over here and
this is the current quantity demanded
now if all of a sudden actually for any
price that I pick if the price of
gasoline increases in consumers will
just have less money in their pocket the
cost of of maintaining and using a car
at any price would go up and so they
might be willing to buy less cars
because the the operating cost has gone
up and this would be true at any price
at any price and so one way to think
about it is the entire demand curve the
way I've just phrased it you could view
for the entire demand curve would shift
so if we call this d1 here now this
would be d2 so here we would say change
in demand and in this case our change in
demand it would shift it would go down
it could you could view it as
shifting to the left actually let me
write that as shifting to the left
because that's what it looks like on
this graph let's do this third example
prices of public transportation goes
down what would happen is this a change
in quantity demanded or would be a shift
in the demand curve
well once again for any for any given
price that we are talking about whether
we're talking about here or whether
we're talking about here the substitute
or one of the substitutes which is
public transportation is now looking
more favorable so you can imagine people
at a given price will just not demand
the market will just not demand as much
of a quantity and so this once again
would be a change in the demand curve
when something is true for any given
price along the curve then you know that
you're going to be shifting the curve so
our change in demand and once again
we're going to shift to the left so it's
similar to a bullet point - now let's
see here we say the state lowers vehicle
registration fees pause this video and
think about that well once again
regardless of where we might be sitting
along the demand curve now if
registration fees has gone down now the
total cost of ownership of a car has
gone down and so for any given price
people might be able to demand a little
bit more car and so here we would have a
shift of the demand curve to the right
shift of the demand curve to the right
we could call this D 3 right over here
so we have a change in the entire demand
curve not just quantity demanded and we
are going to the right let's do this
what is this the fifth example a
recession leads to falling household
incomes pause this video and think about
it
well falling high sold incomes is
actually analogous in some way so the
price of gasoline increases because
people are just gonna have less incomes
regardless of what point we are on the
on the curve people are just going to be
able to buy less so that's going to
shift the demand curve the entire demand
curve to the left so it's a shift in
demand or a change in demand once again
going to the left last but not least
consumers expect new car prices to rise
next year what is that going to do to
either is that going to be a change in
demand or a change in quantity demanded
pause the video and think about and
think about it
well once again this is something that
applies regardless of where we happen to
sit at a given moment on the curve
whatever the equilibrium price is and
we'll talk more about that in other
videos this is generally going to apply
to any point that we are on the curve if
people expect prices to increase if all
of a sudden there's a bolt and it says
hey car prices are going to double next
year well then you could imagine
wherever we are on the curve people are
going to say oh if car prices are going
to double next year I better buy more
car right now so our entire demand curve
is going to shift to the right so it's a
change in the entire demand curve and it
is going to go to the right so the big
picture here if we're talking about a
change in well you could save a change
in a particular price you know someone
raises the price or lowers the price
well that's going to change the quantity
demanded and later when we draw the
supply curve and we see where they
intersect and you have an equilibrium
price when one or both of the curves
shift they're intersecting point changes
and so then you will you could have a
shift in the curves which will then
result in a change in the quantity
demanded but if we're talking about
things that are generally too true
regardless of where we are on the curve
that will just affect people's general
demand for something that is going to
shift the entire curve it's going to be
a change in demand versus a change in
quantity demanded